i wanted the american voter
to have as much information as possible
going into the 2020 election
which they clearly didn't have going
into 2016 and i think
i i hoped anyway that that coupled with
the evidence of his increasingly
cruel bizarre behavior uh would help
make
the case uh more effectively but you
know what
uh the critics of you say you know what
uh donald trump and those around him say
about this book is is that um
your father freddie died so young sadly
died at the age of 42 after
a long battle with alcoholism you and
your brother
got cut out of of the will from uh from
fred the grandfather and
and that you're you're bitter and this
is why you've written the book
you know uh if that had been the case i
could have
and should have written the book five or
ten years
ago when donald was a very well-known
public figure
but didn't have the power he now has to
retaliate against private citizens
uh also that lawsuit was 20 years ago um
i have lived a lot of my life since then
and it would be a sad commentary on me
if i had been hanging on to any
bitterness the book was
i wrote the book primarily as an
american citizen not so much as
his niece and certainly not somebody who
is
looking for revenge well you're uh now a
trained
psychologist or a qualified psychologist
as a clinician say you were someone
outside
how would you analyze donald trump
as a patient you know i don't think we
need necessarily to know what happened
to him at two and a half
to realize that this is somebody who
has serious um psychological disorders
that have never been treated
and continue to worsen over time i think
his behavior and his comments
just lay bare uh the the essential
nature of this this man he is a weak
person
who feels the need to portray himself as
strong
he's willing to sacrifice anybody on the
altar of that endeavor
um by saying the things he's been saying
he has put in danger millions more
americans
by telling them to go out and not be
afraid of something that can
kill you and is killing people every day
you're very clear in the book he's not
just bad as you describe it at managing
this crisis you say
no one is less equipped than my uncle to
manage
no one you say he's the worst yeah and i
i think we saw that from the very
beginning and partially it's because
directly because of his
psychopathologies
he was incapable of admitting the
severity
of kovid 19 from the start because
he cannot be associated with any
negativity
whatsoever and then he was incapable of
course correcting because course
correcting means that you did something
wrong
and he can't admit that he's wrong can i
just ask you about the
unrest we've seen on the streets of so
many american cities
in particular since the death of george
floyd and and this statement again
from the book i can only imagine you say
that donald wished it had been his knee
on george floyd's neck that is quite
something to say donald is a very weak
person and
essentially he's a terrified little boy
and he expends an enormous amount of
energy
trying to keep himself from that reality
and
trying to keep other people from uh
finding that
out so he needs to pretend he's a tough
guy
but if you look at his statements
historically
at his rallies for example he's always
telling other
people to commit the violence
um it's never he's never the one
saying he's going to take care of it um
because he's a physical coward and he it
makes him feel
important i guess to get other people to
do his bidding
but it makes him uh incredibly dangerous
because we always have to remember that
a lot of his motivations for doing the
things he does like
calling in the national guard or um
people who don't seem to be affiliated
with any
police force that we're aware of to sick
them on peaceful protesters
is to assuage his own fragile ego
and i don't uh i suspect after this
conversation need to ask you which way
you are going to vote but you also feel
again
from the book that if donald trump is
re-elected it will be the end you say
of american democracy i i think it's
hard to argue
that um our institutions have
not been under assault since january
2017. we are losing
faith in them because they are being
undermined at every turn
from the state department and the
justice department
to the post office which is something i
never thought i would have to say
um even things like noah which
help us understand and track hurricanes
uh have been under assault
so i don't think it's an overstatement
at this point to suggest that american
democracy which is already under threat
uh is going to erode even
farther and honestly that's the least of
it